Simplifica "n" al cuadrado por "r" a la quinta por "n" a la -7 y expresa tu respuesta en forma exponencial
con exponentes positivos...
déjame reescribir esta expresión acá abajo...
Tenemos "n" al cuadrado por "r" a la quinta
por "n" elevado a la -7.
La manera más simple de hacer esto, antes de hacer la multiplicación
es agrupar los términos que tienen la misma base.
En esta expresión tenemos 2 términos
que tienen la misma base "n",
"n" al cuadrado y "n" elevado a la -7,
entonces podemos reescribir esta expresión
como "n" al cuadrado, "n" a la -7,
"r" a la quinta.
Y esto, ¿a qué va a ser igual?
Bueno tenemos "n" al cuadrado
por "n" a la -7,
en este caso sumamos los exponentes,
de tal manera que esto de aquí
va a ser igual a
"n" elevado a la 2 menos 7
2 menos 7 es -5,
esto es "n" a la -5 que multiplica a "r" a la quinta.
Y ya hemos simplificado al máximo la expresión,
pero aún no hemos concluido porque nos piden que expresemos nuestra respuesta en forma exponencial
y con exponentes positivos... positivos...
y aquí tenemos un exponente negativo,
esta respuesta no es la adecuada
de acuerdo a lo que nos están pidiendo.
Ahora "n" a la -5...
"n" a la -5...
lo podemos escribir como 1 sobre "n" a la quinta, podemos usar eso en esta expresión.
Así es que esto de aquí, este término lo podemos expresar como 1 entre "n" a la quinta,
que multiplica a "r" a la quinta,
lo cual es igual a "r" a la quinta sobre
"n" a la quinta... sobre "n" a la quinta.
Ya está en su forma más simple.
Quizás lo que podíamos hacer aquí,
dado que "r" y "n" están elevados a la quinta,
escribir esto como "r" entre "n"
y eso elevado a la quinta,
pero con esta respuesta ya hemos cumplido
con lo que nos están pidiendo,
que es expresar con exponentes positivos,
y lo hemos cumplido con pasar ese exponente
"n" a la -5 como "n" a la quinta en el denominador.